[Music]
and fellowships we have had in the
course of this lectureship a very very
distinguished group of people beginning
with Bill Lenoir in 1990 and our last
speaker in 1998 was dr. John Logsdon
from from DC this afternoon speaker is a
friend of many of ours in this area dr.
Peter glazier retired a few years ago as
the vice president a vice president of
Arthur D little where he for many years
he founded and for many years ran the
space research program at our third a
little dr. Glazer was born in
Czechoslovakia was educated in England
at Leeds College of Technology as he was
fortunate enough to escape from wartime
for wartime Europe received his degree
there in 1940 43 and then listed in the
Free Czech army which was part of the
British Army and participated in the
battle to Liberty to liberate Europe at
one point in the progression through
through Europe and that battle the the
free Czech army was transferred to the
control of the US Army under General
Patton and went as far as Pilsen at the
time of VE Day at which point peace was
declared they were liberated and Peter
returned to his homeland of
Czechoslovakia for a nervous period of
several of three years wondering what
the Russians were going to do do about
it his parents had returned from
Czechoslovakia to be from England to
Czechoslovakia he took advantage of that
time to get a second degree in
mechanical engineering from the from the
Czech Technical University in Prague and
in 1948 when the Russians did take over
the role rule of Czechoslovakia with a
very firm
and he was fortunate enough to be able
to get out on just about the last plane
to the United States with his mother
where he was able to convert his
knowledge of mechanical engineering and
the ten dollars in a suitcase that he
came to the US with to a job with a
textile company doing mechanical
engineering in New York they thought
highly enough of him that they
encouraged him to go for an advanced
degree which he did at Columbia
University getting him a master's and
eventually a PhD in mechanical
engineering the subject of his PhD
thesis which had to do with particulate
matters in vacuum in 1955 turned out to
be very key a few years later to the
issue of trying to understand the lunar
surface which after all was particularly
matter in a vacuum
and dr. Glazer was able to contribute a
very very important very important
contribution to the success of the u.s.
Apollo program and lunar landing a
program in the soft landings that took
place before it by it by analyzing the
data that was coming back from looking
at the lunar surface optically and
concluding that in fact it was not a
mile deep of of light powder as had been
predicted by some who were doubters of
the possibility of carrying of being
able to light anything at all on the
moon and as many of you know NASA to the
in a bold step went ahead with the with
the plans for soft landing and was able
to to succeed remarkably he initiated
and ran from 1955 on to his retirement
in 1994 the space program at Arthur D
little Arthur need a little of the
course of that put more experiments on
the moon than anyone else and what he is
probably best known for for most of us
is the invention of the bit of the
concept of space solar power he is the
author of a book solar power satellites
published by Wiley in 1997
and those of you who read Technology
Review may recall that he was all the
his concept and his design was on the
cover not not too long ago the error the
issue of space solar power has once
again like a phoenix arisen and i think
it's something that we will be wanting
to pay a great deal of attention to
without taking any more of his time i'd
like you to introduce i'd like to
introduce our distinguished speaker
peter glazier
[Applause]
thank you very much professor young
ladies and gentlemen students and
visitors from the faculty it is a great
pleasure for me to address you on a
topic which has occupied my interest for
more than thirty years I will try and in
my presentation show you the slides
because they're doing far better jobs
and my speaking to you to show you that
the concept that I have proposed
publicly for the first time in 1968 is
indeed worth while studying and I'm
pleased to share with you that today
this is a major interest internationally
and it's being taken seriously all over
the world I will show you slides which
hopefully will illustrate some of the
points that I would normally want to
make and have you get a feel that what
some people called science fiction is
actually the reality in your lives so if
I may
I wanted to just start with this very
short quote from Stephen Jay Gould
because we should not take for granted
that the presence of humanity is
guaranteed on planet Earth
and basically my feeling has been for
these many years that behind this is the
capability to utilize appropriate energy
sources find effective uses for the
energy and at the top of my list is to
safeguard the earth ecology in the
broadest sense that it can be done the
point that I make here is that we are in
a different world in the 21st century
because we have to increase the living
standards of people we have to stabilize
population growth we have to safeguard
the ecology and we have to avert
respective future Wars and how easy it
is to start a war we have we are seeing
right now there are two aspects here
that we have to bear in mind first of
all global population which is just
about six billion to sort of put this
into perspective when I was in high
school there were two billion people on
earth we expect by the middle of a
century to be at around nine and towards
the end perhaps fourteen now as more and
more people increase their living
standards they need to use energy
although we do the best we can
to minimize the wrong way of using
energy and if you look at terawatts of
energy yeah around 14 now it would be
around 27 by mid-century and 42 at the
end these are unimaginable numbers based
on what we now believe we have as energy
sources totally unimaginable this is a
very simple example here oh yeah thank
you a very simple example five thousand
eight hundred million tons 1950 18700
1985 and we now project twenty eight
thousand six hundred and the most
interesting aspect is that the
developing countries will use half of
the energy in the world and I always
find that people don't realize that
there are only two countries which
really are important in the next century
one is China and the other is India
purely in population now there are a
number of energy economists who try and
predict when will be you well when will
we get to this highest point now some
say we've already passed it some others
say we will probably get it by 2010 and
only a few say we will reach it by 2020
it is nearly immaterial when the actual
point will be reached we have learned
how to live with an ever increasing
availability of energy we have no idea
what we will be doing as a
decreasing and here's mm it's just
fairly rapid decrease that we have to
worry about there is nothing inside that
will allow us now to say we will have
the energy we need without destroying
the ecology of the earth let me just
show you the problem we are facing if we
utilize oil gas nuclear it has already
upstream effect you know coal mines etc
we need water for electric power
generation and look all the sort of but
things that are happening in the air in
the water on land and if it's nuclear we
have the storage problem so please keep
that in mind that those are the issues
that the conventional and I put nuclear
among them have to face now look at the
co2 emissions in the SU co2 emissions
coal is of course the greatest culprit
oil LNG and only low ones are nuclear
and solar power satellites now those of
you who have studied nuclear power
realize that it is a clean source up to
a point because where the difficulty
arises we generate plutonium in the
process unless we have developed fast
breeder reactors but even then they have
some problems Fusion is certainly a very
interesting possibility at some time in
the future and I am a simple-minded
engineer who says I am a hundred percent
for fusion
100 percent
because I can now use an existing fusion
reactor which we call the Sun what
happens with co2 well I like this
cartoon because it does indicate that we
have a problem ahead of us and this is a
United Nations study which came up is a
results what are the effects of
sea-level rise on people living in the
Pacific now you see the profound impact
and so on they're about 300 million
people affected by this now
please imagine if we have a problem this
the cost of Albanians and finding ways
for them to live what would we do is 300
million people and finding other places
to live all of that is not old stuff
actually all of this was already known
in the 60s and it was because I was in a
very fortunate position at Arthur T
little that I was able to work these
people who knew all about power beaming
or wireless power transmission Raytheon
was neighbor and so I was able to come
up with what people then said was
obviously science fiction and that is
and that's the first artists concept
that we have solar cells this was a disc
which rotated that they are very thin
films the power was fed transmitting
antenna and directed back to the earth
whether power could be safely and very
efficiently again converted into
electricity
now these was a that's the exact slide
are used in 68 and I have not changed my
mind at all in terms of what are the
criteria technical feasibility economic
attractiveness ecological impact social
desirability political implications and
public acceptance that is what I believe
sort of all the things that we have to
do when we develop new energy sources
now let me go up big in history you know
I'm an engineer and as an engineer I've
been taught over the years a good
engineer basically has to be somewhat
lazy because he has to look where are
some good ideas that some of the
physicists came up with so that we can
adapt them well here is one physicist
whose name you know Tesla because Tesla
bought it in 1908 he built this job is
money from mr. Astor and what he wanted
to do is be in power now it didn't quite
succeed because the technology wasn't
there but he was on the right track and
of course he realized that without Tesla
it wouldn't have all the lights that we
enjoy now the other major interesting
device which was developed by Raytheon
was the microwave generator now this
device all of you know you use it most
of use it every day in a microwave oven
now we you know if you've got 300
million ovens in use now tremendous
saving in energy now in space if we want
to use wireless power transmission for
use in space
we don't need glass enclosures we don't
need any of that stuff
and what we left as those two
little things the magnets in the innards
of a microwave generator the second
thing that we need is a way of
converting microwaves directly into DC
it was considered an impossible task
quite a few years ago except a very good
friend of mine bill brown who worked at
Raytheon who unfortunately died just
recently developed the dipole rectifier
which converts the microwaves directly
into DC these are dipoles and here
solid-state devices which do this job
now what you're looking at is one of the
first microwave converters the beam
converters type of rectifiers Bill Brown
I think it was 1954 had an assignment
from wrong Air Force Base to be able to
build a helicopter which would stay up
forever if power is provided from the
ground and lo and behold he demonstrated
that this helicopter he has a blades was
able to fly as long as power is provided
to him a remarkable demonstration he
also showed that this is a very
efficient way of transmitting power DC
to DC conversion microwave beam let's
say my focus in this the microwave beam
in the collection and if you look at all
of this at that time already it was
about 55 percent efficient that is from
DC to DC
now you may recall that we've learned
how to produce very large antennas in
order to give you an idea what the size
of this antenna is this is a truck here
so we know we can build phased array
antennas as these are called they are
used by the Air Force in various places
that's in the Arctic contact the Arctic
region Alaska so back in 1970 with all
this knowledge base
I had the temerity with my boss who was
at that time General James Gavin to be
able to meet this the NASA managers and
this explained to them what a solar
power satellite could do and NASA felt
that indeed is a project of great
interest to them and what they decided
is to study this and there was a team
that was formed is Arthur D little
Raytheon Grumman and spectral a part of
Textron you see I had people in the East
who I knew who would work with us and
this was the first large-scale SPS
system that was designed solar cells on
a large platform this is a antenna and
the only moving part is the antenna is
because as this is in geosynchronous
orbit once a day would have to move with
respect to the earth and there's the
bearing now you're looking at the
underside of this face of phased array
antenna this is where the wave comes out
microwaves here is the device which
produces a microwaves
is that the microwaves are then fed into
the rest of the antenna and these are
cooling devices that it rejects any
waste heat the space here you see the
antenna on the ground please note that
this is semi-transparent and we can
still use a land underneath the antenna
it's a large and ground area that we
need and we use a safety zone and a lot
more to say about well this is as you
can see the NASA SPS system circa of
1975 it's a very large area receiver and
this is a area receiver rectifying
antenna I was concerned that NASA went a
bit overboard because it was too large
and the output of this was 5 gigawatts
now that's a very respectable energy
output now if you recall the previous
slide that I've shown for fossil fuels
this is the same slide now applied to
satellite power systems much simplified
and all the problems that you saw with
the others there is nothing happening on
earth in terms of waste products there's
a lot of you know science and technology
behind this I just wanted to show you
that it's fairly basic to understand
what we need to do in terms of sizing
that's a parameter called tau and it's
equal to the square root of transmitting
antenna and the receiving antenna
divided by lambda the wavelengths and
the distance between the transmitting
antenna in the
NASA realized that we need to have large
launch systems and therefore they
they've studied see launch and that you
know it's not fair has not been
forgotten because as a company which
wants to do that now again nobody
believed that this can be done you know
they said well these are just paper
studies and how in the world would you
really show us that this can be done and
so NASA allowed us to use Goldstone in
[Music]
1974 and this Goldstone antenna saud we
had venus antenna that we could use
that's a Venus sorry
that's a Venus antenna and we put a
microwave generating device at the focal
point and then beamed from there to a
receiving antenna on this large pole and
we had lights connected to it so as we
moved this antenna we could show the
lights dimming and so on indicating that
we were getting power this is a view of
the receiving antenna and people ask me
well why didn't you complete it very
simple answer they run out of money
these are the lights and as we move the
antenna back and forth you could see the
lights dimming and getting brighter
there were questions of course asked now
what if you do something to heating up
the ionosphere at the wavelengths that
we are talking about two point four five
gigahertz by the way it's in the isn
band industrial scientific medical band
so they don't interfere with other
people and the concern was real we
didn't have the answer
that time so what we did we manage to
get an experiment in the Arecibo large
dish and we had a diagnostic radar in
this location here in Guadeloupe and
therefore we were heating the ionosphere
by putting energy into it microwave
energy you see here's the microwaves
being reflected by this huge dish
thousand four antennae going up through
the ionosphere and the radar showed us
it's not heating up well that was a
great relief to all and I think by then
we had enough information and NASA had
continued working on this till 1980 in
1980 the Department of Energy said well
you know we already believes that beyond
this time we will have nuclear power
totally available in the United States
and all of our energy will come from
nuclear power furthermore they said that
in 10 years we will have demonstrated
controlled fusion
so essentially NASA was told well you
don't have to work on it and you'll do
these other things and you know you're
still waiting for control and fusion of
course in 1986 there was a big study by
the National Commission on space in
pioneering of space frontier and here is
sort of the key statement what their
ambition is opening new resources to
benefit humanity by combining energy of
the Sun base materials left in space
during the formation of the solar system
now what that means going to the moon
and building stuff on the moon itself
now there are a lot of experiments and
work that was ongoing then and we were
able to show
if it would have experiment with a
shuttle we could learn a lot and
demonstrate how this works and we were
going to use a Spartan free flying
platform ok free flying platform it
would be into the shuttle this was done
with Space Center at Texas A&M
University and these sought me nearly
had permission to use a shuttle but then
as I wouldn't allow it because of the
interest in all of this there were
several other places were microwave
power transmission was of growing
interest and one was in Europe Europe
has made a study that they cannot rely
on renewable energy sources and the only
sources they can have is a nuclear or
coal and none of them you know remember
some of the problems of nuclear Russia
etc attractive so they said what we'd
like to do is take some of the power
from South America and for example
Venezuela has a guru dam which has
enormous capacity and also in Brazil and
whereas other places so they said all we
need is to have a reflector and that
reflectors and if we generate power from
various sources here that reflector will
beam up and we reflect back and we had a
space in Spain allocated to this and it
looked like a very interesting project
but the Europeans found out that it'll
cost more than they wanted to spend on
this so they didn't go ahead with it now
there's another aspect to all of this
and that is where do people live and we
have studied the possibility of putting
these antennas receiving antennas not on
land because it takes land which might
have to be used for raising
food but we put it in the ocean and this
shows you the size of antenna for five
gigawatts in the ocean and then has a
dual purpose because we can use it as a
fish farm you know if you want to have
salmon these days it doesn't come from
the river as much it comes from against
Norway where the fish farm salmon so
here we have the possibility of dual
usage this just indicates how we take
care of the environment at sea by having
our dipoles and other stuff encapsulated
and it's supported there now this was
not just a hypothetical experiment let's
see if I can get this go back here
can you
oh thank you that's great
there was a big conference at Ocean
City's in 95 in fact there's another one
slated and what's interesting you know
we mentioned about the population growth
all of the attendee said we can't have
all these people living on land they
have to live in the ocean and that
indicates to you as I believe a typical
question that people asked you know how
do we control that beam little to the
west Harry we almost lost Detroit and I
think it's rather important to
understand this is not a desperate this
beam has enormous energy which it can
provide but look at these numbers the
power density at the edge of the retina
is 1 milli watt per square centimeter at
the fence line it's 0.1 milli watt per
square centimeter and we expect that by
the time we have it done it will be down
to 0.01 milliwatt
now if you live in New York or Paris
bossiness gets to be what you're exposed
to from all the devices that you're
using particularly when you're listening
to them on a phone I just thought I'll
show you the microwave field exposure
guidelines
the OSHA is that's you know industry
uses large amounts of microwaves for
various purposes and they're about eight
millivolts and different organization
let's say go down to five and the public
is exposed to 0.5 well you know that's
not too far removed from what we are
talking about for the buildings at the
edge of the antenna the only sort of
group that has been very low is USSR and
this is a purely hypothetical level
which of course they never achieved if
you use a microwave oven you might be
interested what you're exposed to and if
you look at one milliwatt you'd have to
be within you know what less than a foot
six inches of the microwave oven by the
time you get four feet away you really
are at a very low level you cannot be
concerned about and that's basically
what we expect will happen at the
receiving antenna as well now somebody
asked her what if it fails well here is
a failure mode Eastern European
standards and total failure and this is
partial failure and the total failure
would be around this level again there's
nothing that I believe needs to be done
at that level and we of course have some
control of the things in orbit as well
nobody believed us you remember my offer
of the ghouls flying nobody believed us
that birds can fly through the beam and
nothing happens to them so we worked
with a Boston University honor on
ethology Center and studied vism the
type of behavior under what species the
exposure and flux density and so on and
does that have any effect we looked for
all sorts of effects and the upshot was
no effect visible now if we have power
density at great distance we would be at
around that I'm gonna go back here
[Music]
how do I get it back that's the second
button yeah thank you
10 to minus 4 milli watt per square
centimeter is sort of if we really are
along a great distance away at that
level no concern at all about microwaves
there have been many other uses of this
kind of approach one is a high-flying
aircraft which I've been studying again
actually this was for the Air Force some
years ago and it looked like a very
interesting approach now the Japanese
and many other countries have followed
very closely our work you know it isn't
classified and everyone can write papers
about it and in this international space
year they arranged to fly this kite so
to speak and they had a Nissan truck and
this thing on flies and here is the
device which makes it possible it's on
top of the Nissan vehicle and the
airplane therefore as long as you
provide power the airplane will fly the
Canadians worked on it they called it
sharp stationary high altitude relay
platform all this is for communications
purposes and this round saying is a
receiving antenna it's done by the
communications department and it flies
the Japanese started to work on this
probably in 1973 I had the pleasure of
meeting these people there in 1974 in
Tokyo and they really felt that this was
the answer to their needs they came up
with what's called the SBS 2000 project
and you know it's the same idea you
being from solar cells and you've been
back to earth and this wasn't
hypothetical as you can see they
actually started to build these
structures and trying to understand how
to design those kind of structures they
had a visit of various people here a
whole group of them and the interesting
Japan External Trade Organisation to
talk about their R&D and what we are
doing and what can be done another thing
that has happened in Japan is dirigibles
you know if you want to have a dirigible
to stay up forever what you do is have
an transmitter which sends a signal
there's a array produces power said it's
kept up there and there it flies forever
if you'd like to have it fly doing all
the things from the altitude for example
Communications another thing that the
Japanese data rising a very interesting
project this was a rocket on which they
mounted transmitters and receivers of
microwaves these are just some of the
details of it
again we worked with Texas A&M on it and
that they developed dipolar rectifiers
which are two-dimensional and now you
see the whole rocket and this is what it
was supposed to do and it did it the
microwave experiment transmission system
beam power from the rocket to a
satellite now that is a very important
demonstration with a lot of interesting
possibilities
in Germany it was of great interest as
well if you this is power from space the
Russians of course followed what we were
doing very closely and I was at in the
1980s a chairman of the space Power
Committee of the International
Astronautical Federation and he had some
Russians on the committee and I said
fellas we are telling you what we are
doing we'd like you to tell us what
you're doing and so in 1985 October in a
Stockholm meeting a very senior
scientist professors are Christian of
the Moscow Aviation Institute in the
cosmos Council gave us his paper saying
what we are doing this is a very
interesting saying look at it in 1990
somewhere around here they were going to
light up the Earth from space then they
would energetic transmission of energy
through space and so on ending up with
solar power satellite demonstration by
they have pictures of some of their
devices I don't know if you've read it
but on schedule that time they launched
a giant space mirror now the reason for
learning how to do that is because the
thin film solar cells are then mounted
on the mirror
it isn't just to reflect sunlight that's
a good thing to tell the people in the
press and this is a mirror during
deployment they had hoped and a gia had
hoped to do this earlier this year but
unfortunately they the mirror which was
85 feet diameter collided with the
spacecraft in a didn't deploy which is
too bad they did another thing which we
have to look at was quite a feat from
Mia they called it a mere plasma beam
they sent to a Swedish satellite called
Freya now I'll let you imagine what this
means with some moving things in orbit
and it was a successful experiment
therefore just showing you the
sophistication that these people already
have for it nASA has recovered from the
defeat of do is you know stopping their
program in 1980 and about two years ago
started was called a fresh look on space
power and this made the front page in
May 1997 of aerospace America they have
now 15 million dollars to study it at
NASA Marshall Space Flight Center and as
you can see it looks different than the
old NASA SPS reference system has very
interesting advantages there's lots you
can read about it you probably recognize
this picture and I have lived on the
moon vicariously for many years so I
have great interest in doing the things
I've just told you on the moon
and I couldn't help but show you this
experiment the laser ranging
retroreflector experiment was placed on
the moon July 16th 1969 by Buzz Aldrin
good friend of mine and it's the only
experiment still being used by about 70
investigators not just to measure the
earth-moon distance but all sorts of
other things there's a laser built into
a telescope at Haleakala mountain on
hawaii sends a beam of laser and the
palace laser and we can measure time
accurately etc this is sort of a
high-school problem how you can
determine the distance from the
telescope to this device very accurately
we've studied all sorts of things that
would be done on the moon and how we can
use that and of interest is that we can
utilize energy on these our northern and
southern poles and have it continuous
and then feed it to antennas like you
see in the background and beam power
back to earth as well as what I have
proposed that if you have a laser which
is powerful enough and we have all the
power there we need we can change the
way asteroids and other kind of
unpleasant visitors come into our
neighborhood by directing them into
another orbit there's a business here as
well of course and that's why many
countries are very interested and I've
mentioned a few of them it may be
perhaps a bit but optimistic to say that
services in energy will start in about
three four or five years however it's a
lot cheaper to provide energy to Space
Station and to other kind of things we
have up there than to rely on batteries
so I think this is an additional path
holidays that I see coming now what's my
vision for the future it has to be
consistent this economic and political
realities has to be acceptable to global
village inhabitants and action or by
industry and other decision makers in
government so that is a very quick sort
of journey into space looking for power
and I'll be delighted to try and answer
some of your questions okay it's a very
good question let me say I'm one of the
biggest supporter of utilizing as much
solar energy on the ground in renewables
I served as president of the
International solar energy society and
therefore my I'm impartial whatever we
can do in the ground I think we have to
do there's a problem on the ground it's
a one shift operation in space it's a
three shift operation in other words the
Sun shines there continuously on the
ground we have not only day and night
but weather conditions and that makes it
difficult for the kind of large-scale
power production that we have in mind we
should do all we can on the small scale
Singh hot water heaters on the roof
suits that are whatever we can do on the
ground will be fabulous but on the
bigger scheme of things it will not be
enough to replace the fuels that we now
use
are there any current application areas
for microwave power transmission I'm
delighted you asked the question we have
worked this the state of Alaska because
they have places where they want to beam
power that away because the cost of
laying power cables across the inlets
and so on it's very expensive and we
have identified this as a very
interesting thing and if you go to the
University of Alaska at Fairbanks you
will find that they have taken the all
the equipment that NASA had at Goldstone
you know which we used and transported
it there for exactly that purpose and
they're engaged in finding out where
does it make sense for example the
native population wants power and to get
power to them is exceedingly difficult
so that's underway it's a very
interesting possibility
the disadvantage is that you can't do it
next week we have to have a number of
things going I've discussed primarily
the system itself now I have not
discussed how do we get there from here
you know as long as it costs us a
fortune per pound to lift things into
geosynchronous orbit this will not be a
good way of going I'm convinced that
there are better ways of lifting
materials from the earth into orbit one
that I have worked on is magnetic
acceleration and most of the stuff I've
shown you can withstand 10,000 G's so
that's one aspect we have to change our
view of how we place material into orbit
the second we cannot have astronauts as
skilled as they may be in my friends
doing these wrenches and hammers and
screwdrivers putting this together the
only way I think this can be done if you
look at the scale is by having robots in
robotic assembly we've learned it on the
ground go to any large assembly plant
you don't see many people around it's
done robotically people are still
required to guide the robots basically
this is something that we will have to
learn again we have started to look at
the robotic assembly in space can you
imagine what it took to assemble the
International Space Station the risks
are astronauts had this is where we have
to learn how to do it robotically I
believe it is possible and there are
people studying it
I'm sorry oh well my preference is
gallium arsenide cells or cadmium
telluride a number of very good
materials which you can use in very thin
film layers so that the mass of that
stuff NASA and the SPS references
believe it or not try to talk him out of
it used crystalline a single crystal
silicon solar cells which was not the
way to go because a thick and heavy and
so on thin film cells that she already
can see for example I had a discussion
with a man from the Yaffe Institute I
don't know if that means something in
Leningrad there the National Renewable
Energy Lab in equivalent in Russia and
they have developed solar cells which
are about the size of the nail of my
pink which are 25% efficient and there's
hardly anything there and they use a
concentrator so there are novel ways to
utilize thin film cells it hardly in
comparable to what we now use and I
believe those other kind of developments
that are on in the laboratory now and
will eventually be applied
[Music]
beyond limits
mr. girls and so forth now you in to see
whether the
he's seen in crisis
I'm familiar with business and I fully
agree with it and I believe the only way
that we can reduce population growth is
if you study the American system of
population growth and higher living
standards you don't have to have large
families because you're sure that one or
two are enough for you to have people
who will take care of you in the old age
and I think that these models are very
important the inputs that they can get
and I would suggest example from the
NASA people and the fresh looks that it
would be very important to integrate
because I'm a technical optimists and I
believe that there is this in collective
brains enough new idea that we can do
all these things without seeing the end
of the world
but really major difficulty sure we have
lots of things on the ground that use
robotics in factories areas so in order
to say it up do you really think that
well actually I believe to some extent
it will but there is a limit to this and
I don't believe having this in orbit
around the earth is the right place at
all
you saw that slides that I've shown to
convince you that we should go back on
look at the moon as a place to put these
for a number of reasons and the primary
one is we have the materials the cost of
materials they're the same kind of
materials we have on earth and therefore
we can establish the materials that we
need up there and have the factories to
make them we don't have to have these
enormous heavy lift launch vehicles that
NASA you know was thinking about and I
believe that they're the assembly again
is a lot easier than in orbit and that
the robots may be required for certain
things if you know to get us to that
stage but eventually I think being on
the moon will be the answer because
you're on Luna firma you know not just
tariff
I don't think so I think we can we would
probably have mirror rotating in a rest
position which would allow us to do
without the rotation
you know the mirror itself no that's
that's a distance at this point it's
primarily still NASA which is know in
other countries is the government as
well and you know today and I didn't
mention that the Chinese are very
interested the Europeans the Japanese
Russian the Ukraine you know it's it's a
if you want to be at a meeting of the
next we had one in Tokyo
January 9th we had one on the reunion
island which was organized by a CNES a
French Space Agency and if you know
that's in the Indian Ocean because they
want to use it there and we have another
one coming up at the Space Studies
Institute in May and at uni Space 3 is
all day devoted to this so I think
there's a lot of people who are now
involved in it and hopefully the various
people like yourself come up with new
ideas and better ideas than we have had
so far
and application sharing a few moments I
have this certificate of appreciation
for doctor for his space public this is
electron space solar power and energy
supply systems are thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you very much